[Musique]
enfin les enfants n'ont que l'aventuré
l'on remet toi nounours nicolas et
pimprenelle attendent l aventure je vais
vite leur raconter mon école elop
laventure hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop aux
grandes lignes et comment barre d'une
rivière à huy où mes enfants je ne peux
plus gros noms de tout soufflé qu'est ce
qui t'arrive ouf je crois que je suis
poursuivi par un gendarme
ferme la fenêtre nicolas
olala de l'histoire j'ai voulu aller
chercher des cailloux du sarde et
quelques friandises au bord de la
rivière pour ces petits poissons rouges
et un dédale non oui comment le ce tube
accès drôle et il savait pas nager pas
très bien mais un monsieur m'a aidé à
sortir de l'eau seulement ce monsieur
peut-être un gendarme il est interdit de
pêcher dans cette rivière tu me dis
oh oui une voix terrible mais je ne
pêche pas monsieur quand je lui ai
répondu je leur base du sobre et des
cailloux or ils disent tous la même
chose
braconnier et ce panier de pêcheurs
nous nous sommes disputés
je me suis sauvée et me voilà avec
montpellier ouf
donner des bons rails ou rose
[Musique]
ça
va j'ai dû d'ulysse pourquoi son vous
allez voir commune un petit pas se
regarder ce que de noces vous a apporté
ça y est les gourmands et vient manger
ce que ça a l'air bon pape rhône elle ne
mange pas ça
c'est un curieux d'élise et ma beauté
aux non voyons nicolas quel est ton plat
préféré ouais il tartine de camembert et
bien nicolas les poissons n'aime pas les
tartines de fromage et ce qui est bon
pour les poissons n'est pas bon pour les
petits enfants
cattier 10
49 bravo pape rhône elle tue et
raisonnable toi
sable et les cailloux non ce soit il
faut les laisser dormir mais demain
matin vous leur donnerez de l'eau propre
et on l'est reste alors à leurs fins de
rivière exactement
ça mais
[Musique]
ça leur va bien maintenant qu est ce qu
est un pass tenace c'est très mignon à
l'eau on dormait vous vite
poinçonneur
nicolas et poissons ou pas preneur
mais attention j'adore
[Musique]
alors tu es remis de ses émotions soit
va mieux pas trop je n'ai pas compris
pourquoi tu t'es disputé avec le
gendarme il était très gentil il t'a
aidé à sortir de l'eau n'en parlons plus
pas trop
les enfants dorment
boonen
fait deux tours
[Musique]